Carmen caramo de 77 años no ha podido
completar su inmunización contra Kobe 19
por la escasez de la segunda dosis de la
rusa sputnite en Venezuela le
correspondía la segunda inyección en
junio podemos y nos dijeron que que el
siguiente día mi hija fue el siguiente
día
le dijeron que
que no estaban poniendo la vacuna Carmen
que sufre de diabetes y es hipertensa
evita salir de casa no puedo salir tengo
mi casa en el pueblo y no puedo ir no he
podido ir tengo un año como Carmen
muchos otros que fueron vacunados con la
primera dosis de la sputnik hoy no tiene
la certeza de cuándo podrán finalizar su
inmunización dado los retrasos en la
entrega
afuera de un centro de vacunación
repleto de personas está Danilo alianza
de 76 años informaron que no había
vacunas rusas sino la China y no me
perdí a mí para ponerme la segunda
Quienes fueron inoculados con la primera
dosis de la rusa visitan constantemente
su centro de vacunación en busca de
información casi siempre en vano la
mayoría de estos la única vacuna
disponible la china sinofar sin que
hasta ahora se haya recomendado su
combinación Manuel Enrique figuera
presidente de la sociedad venezolana de
infectología Define el plan de
vacunación del gobierno de Venezuela
como político y no técnico están
vacunando sin ningún tipo de estructura
sin ningún tipo de organización sin
planificación con desorden grandes colas
grandes información las personas ni
siquiera saben que van a recibir dónde
lo van a recibir el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro de acuerdo con Rusia la entrega
de 10 millones de unidades pero solo se
conoce que llegaron al país un millón
430.000 Y a medida que la escasez de
vacuna se hace más evidente en los
centros de vacunación es mucho más
difícil poder ingresar a ellos
custodiados por militares y policías
Nico el callsters France 24 Caracas